احنا حاليا بمركز الاواء مدرسه جنين خن
يونس احنا تم نقلنا من المستشفى
الاندونيسي الى هذه المدرسه الغريب في
الموضوع كان انه وجدنا انه المدرسه ها راح
تصبح مستشفى للمصابين وهي كارثه
طبعا بعدت ساعه تحت
الردم يوم في العنايه المركزه معي كسر في
الجمجمه نذيف الكتف نذيف في الرئ ونيف في
الطحال
وكسر بلاتين رجلي كان الوضع مخيف في
الاندليسه عش حولنا على المدرسه هذ الله
يا المستشفى مام اللي والله ط علينا والله
انجينا من
الشبابي
والرصاص هذا المكان في مدرسه خلف المستشفى
الاوروبي
عاملينها ف ميداني لكن تفتقر الى جميع
ادنى الخدمات يعني ويعني حتى العكاكيز مش
قادرين يوفروا لنا اياها
اي
يعني ابسط الامور وفروها بصعوبه جدا جدا
جدا لما وصلت هان تم وصول خبر لي
ان ابني قد استشهد المدرسه له خمس ايام
مستشهد وانا جنبه ابعد عنه امطار وانا مش
عارف ان ونحن نعيش هلقيت في مكان صعب جدا
طلعنا نتعالج ه ما فيش علاج كفايه وا عشان
فيش علاج في وجع في رجلي مش قادره اعدي
الحمام بلبس بنبز ما بقدرش اخش الحمام
ماشش بحس شي بمشي في الجرح بحس شي بحرك في
الجرح ياكلي مش
قادره لا قادره اقف عليها ولا قادره ا
الحمام حتى بعث اجيب بمبان ما لقيتش البنب
ما فيش نلبس لازم اكون في مستشفى لاني انا
تعبانه ما بقدرش لا اقعد لا من بطني ولا
من رجلي ولا من ايدي قله عالم تصوبت قله
امم تصوبت واستشهدوا ناس الله يعين الشعب
على اللي على اللي على اللي وقعت
فيه كارثه والله العظيم انا زعلانه كثير
عليهم حتى الخدمات اللي ننا بنديها اياهم
مش نفس الخدمات اللي ممكن يطلقو
بالمستشفيات يعني لو مريض اي مريض تعب
وصلت حاله حالته ل لمرحله اصعب من اللي هو
اللي فيها مش حتلقى الخدمه انا متاكده انه
راح
يستشهد